it's great to be joined today by Paul
bloom who is professor of psychology at
Yale University and author of the book
against empathy the case for rational
compassion so that this is such a great
topic and it relates to so much of
what's going on in the world and the
United States today let's start by
breaking down some of these terms when
we say empathy what are we talking about
and when you talk about rational
compassion what's the main difference
between that and what we see is empathy
so thanks for having me on David and you
began in an excellent way because people
use empathy in all sorts of ways and you
know as long as we're clear what we're
talking about we could have a productive
discussion so I'm using empathy as many
people use it to refer to the feeling
the feelings of others experiencing
experiences of others often feeling
their pain feeling their suffering and I
distinguish this I argued it that's a
very bad way to live our lives leads us
to all sorts of mistakes political
mistakes personal mistakes it makes us
worse people and I contrast that with
what I call rational compassion and
rationals makes sense enough it's sort
of figuring out what to do based on an
appreciation of constant benefits and
and moral principles and compassion is
the motivator you need something to
motivate you to do good and compassion
is caring about other people but you can
care about other people about feeling
their suffering just by loving them are
feeling close to a wine into them to
their lives to be better and I think
that's a better moral force and talk a
little bit about how that might be
applied to some of the regular political
discussions that are better had and what
came to mind as I was sort of thinking
about our conversation is it seems to me
that particularly since people tend to
often live at least politically sort of
in echo chambers that that often are
confirming their pre-existing biases
selective empathy for lack of a better
term might actually create pretty
significant bias in people in favor of
maybe groups or individuals that they're
already familiar with and may not lead
to optimal sort of political decisions
am I sort of on the right track there
you're exactly on the right track I
think empathy is by its very nature so
of you can force yourself to feel and
pathak towards somebody who looks
different from you is in a different
country or is your political enemy but
it's hard it's much more natural to feel
empathy for your friends for attractive
people for people who look like you for
your same race your same country and
empathy is inherently biased and so we
see this in a political realm all the
time when people want to make arguments
for instance for violence and cruelty
and war often the way they do so is by
generating empathy for people close to
you as a way to motivate outrage from
people to people far away from you we
saw a bit of that in 2016 with
anti-immigrant rhetoric where a lot of
the rhetoric was tilted by saying look
we want you to feel the suffering of
people who are going to lose their jobs
people who are assaulted and raped by
immigrants and this sort of empathy is
used to motivate anger against a group
well the way any reasonable discussion
of immigration should take place is in
terms of cost benefits who do we have an
obligation for what's the best way to
make the world better but appeals to
empathy just muddy things at best and at
worst lead to some really nasty behavior
in part of people well to take that
example I mean everything you're saying
makes sense but what seems to be maybe
missing maybe not deliberately so but
what I think might make sense to think
about is some of the language you're
using starts to take on a sort of
utilitarian message or or paradigm this
idea that we should just measure we
should try to remove emotion and measure
as as practically as possible as
objectively as possible the cost and
benefit of any particular decision but
we know about the pitfalls of strictly
utilitarian ways of analyzing situations
don't we so I'm kind of a lapsed
utilitarian i'm ninety percent
utilitarian but i push back on some of
the the problems you're pointing out so
for instance i love my kids more than
one more than i care about you and I
don't think is anything wrong with that
so you know a true utilitarian would say
your life is as valuable as my son's you
know but but I'm not a true utilitarian
I think that that in some cases there's
certain bonds that have
a reality and and and should be taken
into account another hand I think we do
to be a lot more utilitarian I think
that um that when faced with a situation
where we do one thing five people died
we do another thing a thousand people
will die I say bring on utilitarians in
shoes that act that that kills the
fewest people there's so many cases
where we don't pay attention numbers the
world gets much worse and we
congratulate ourselves of being people
of feeling at least not utilitarian the
the immigration example is interesting
because we did a pretty detailed
analysis of all of the sort of talking
points about why up both documented and
undocumented immigration are bad for the
United States this include included the
desert debunked notion that undocumented
immigrants and and legal immigrants are
more likely to commit crime the
non-existent drain on the economy that
exists all of these aspects and what
what I came away with that relates to
this issue of empathy is you can
actually throw out empathy you can throw
out the argument about whether we should
allow people in aside from potentially
increased crime or or economic detriment
to the to the American economy because
those don't exist it you you could
actually say merely from a utilitarian
perspective it actually does make sense
to have immigrants be a significant part
of the American economy and in some
cases it seems like it actually has the
opposite effect where it's this idea
that many of those people who are
against immigration have that I am here
and I don't want someone who isn't
deserving of what I have to be allowed
in when if we took the utilitarian
approach we might come away with
something very different it's sort of a
reverse situation too much of what
you're discussing making bad decisions
because of empathy we should actually
not be thinking about it and we might
get to a more rational choice in that
particular case I totally agree i think
for something immigration we should
crunch the numbers I mean it's not
merely crunching numbers because there's
also moral questions what our
obligations for people in our own
country other countries what if people
are immigrants and our refugees because
of a mess that we cause what's our
obligation but a lot of it is number
crunching but your analysis is
not going to convince anybody who's been
swayed by emotional Appeals critically
by empathic appeals basically any
large-scale policy is going to have some
winners and losers no matter I agree
with what you're saying but certainly
some immigrants commit crimes sure um
and so I'll you know so somebody like
Ann Coulter will say I want to tell you
a story and two story to be about
somebody who's been raped by an
immigrant documented undocumented
whatever and many of our audience will
listen to that story and then it will
enrage them against immigrants and they
won't care about your numbers and I'd
like to see a world where will always be
vulnerable to the sort of appeal but I
see a world where where it has a lot
less force is taken less seriously we
dismiss empathic arguments can you give
us some examples and you have so many
that you've talked about some are in
your book and summer summer in other
places where you you've spoken of areas
or instances where empathy distorts
judgment and whether it's from you know
medical care education and parenting
marriage you whatever you think might be
the most interesting examples to some in
our audience I'll get to super quick
examples were double policy but it is
also everyday life so take parents I've
been a parent of a teenage teenagers for
a while your teenage son comes up to you
and he's freaking out because he hasn't
done his homework and it's due tomorrow
and there's crisis and he's very anxious
a good parent listens understands loves
his kid but doesn't freak out along with
the kid doesn't share the feelings what
so much of what being a good parent is
is not absorbing the feelings of your
kids not absorbing their pain but trying
to make the world better for them in
some ways saying they're anxious you're
calm they're sad you're cheerful they
don't want to do something you make them
do it because it's for the long-term
interest that's one case a second case
to be a therapist so you're talking to a
therapist and you're very depressed
you're very sad you want your therapist
to understand you you want your
therapist to to care about you you don't
want a therapist to get sad and I guess
the third example is is a first
responder a firefighter or a cop or
something like that where if you're
immensely empathic in the suffering of
other people
you experience you will burn out very
quickly and I've gotten emails and
letters from people who have read my
stuff and I said look you've kind of
helped me understand the distinction
between empathy and compassion which is
I care about people that's good the
problem is I feel are suffering too much
and that's bad hmm any examples with
education I know that's another area
where were you you've spoken about this
how does empathy distort education
potentially so education is an
interesting case because any good
teacher has to get in ahead of his
orders did have to understand what they
know and what they and what they don't
know but um but again here to you need
some sort of emotional distance in order
not just to be an effective teacher but
to be a moral teacher be a good person
um I'll give this sort of a sort of very
mundane example which is sometimes
students come out to me in a very upset
and they won a higher grade and they
might cry it it might just be upset I'm
yeah I'm I'm at Yale so we grade pretty
easily anyway but still they might want
a higher grade is that true and oh yeah
there's there's great inflation like
crazy we could talk about that another
time yeah but um but but and I'm being a
highly empathic person I feel her pain
but it wouldn't be right it wouldn't be
fair for me the elevator students great
simply because he or she is upset
because it's not fair to other students
who don't come crying and and here we
see this basic fairness uh requires sort
of abstracting away from the particular
should pick your feelings and emotions
of people and then an appealing to
broader principles as a general rule are
there any circumstances you've come
across where the the variable of whether
someone is or isn't crying about
something should influence
decision-making in any way um it should
it should this it should influence how
you act to them if you have if you have
a friend who's weeping you know you
console them in a different way than
after or not and certainly people's
emotional responses should matter a lot
but you shouldn't if you feel them
yourself if you if a friend comes to in
great pain and then you feel the pain
now you're in great pain too you've done
nothing to help your friend where you've
done actually as you added a second
yourself and so what a good friend does
is is supportive and understanding is
sad because their friend has said but
tries to respond to France interest in
mind it's a case where empathy is in a
sense selfish where instead of trying to
help you if you're in trouble I become
absorbed with my own feelings in
response to it and now I'm dealing
myself we've been speaking about the
book against empathy the case for
rational compassion with the book's
author professor psychology at Yale
University Paul bloom very interesting
and very relevant also in today's
political world thanks so much for
talking to me about this thank you for
having me on